- BE A GOOD GHOST
AND GRAB MAMA A DRINK.
- I'LL GET YOU A DRINK.
- SHH.
I CAN'T BREATHE!
THANK YOU.
- OF COURSE.
AND I'M SORRY ABOUT BEFORE--
THE STARING.
IT'S JUST YOU LOOK
LIKE MY DEAD WIFE.
- OH, GHOSTMAN.
THAT--I'M SO SORRY.
I DIDN'T KNOW.
R.I.P, LADY GHOSTMAN.
COME HERE.
- WAIT A SECOND.
THAT'S MY WOMAN!
- WHOA, WHAT'S GOING ON?
- OH, GOD.
[groans]
- GET HIM! GET HIM!
- HOLY [bleep].
GUYS! COME ON!
YOU'RE ACTING, WELL...
NUTS ACTUALLY.
- THEY BOTH WANT A PIECE
OF THE JILLY BEAN.
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
DO YOU LIKE THESE GUYS?
- OH, NO. NOT REALLY.
- THEN WHAT'RE YOU DOING?
- WHY YOU TEASING MY DANGLE?
- ALICE CRAPS ON ME A LOT,
AND I JUST WANTED
TO SEE WHAT IT FELT LIKE
TO DO THE CRAPPING.
- GUYS, YOU CAN'T BE TRYING TO
TWIST EACH OTHER'S JOINTS OFF,
MAN.
- HE'S RIGHT.
I ONLY WENT AT YOU SO HARD
'CAUSE WE'RE BOTH SO BADASS.
- WELL, YOU SEE THAT WAITRESS?
I'M GONNA TELL HER
THAT YOU HAVE A MONSTER WANG.